welcome back everyone this is the show
that today will put two master craftsmen
up against one another we're not making
swords or having a bake up that's not
some crank
may this episode is all about famed
director Ridley Scott versus James
Cameron that means we have aliens
terminators and blade runner's deep sea
creatures Martians which are technically
okay I guess aliens and wasn't really a
Martian was just Matt Damon look I'm
just the guy lucky enough to host this
show
I feel like relax leo it's still early
in your movie let's see how you're doing
a couple hours from now now if this was
James Cameron vs. Ridley's brother Tony
Scott it'd be no contest Tony Scott
director Top Gun that's it go home Jim I
don't care if you've actually touched
the real Titanic no no there's two O's
in boots that's right nice man but
really Scott taking on Cameron that's a
knock-down drag-out slobber
knocking slugfest here's how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three iconic boldness and
then we'll do a wildcard round to
determine once and for all who is the
king of sci-fi and occasionally action a
little bit of romance in there and
filmmaking in general [ __ ] mom is it
the guy who directed alien or the dude
who made piranha too but it is gonna
come up despawning here we go
my name is gladiator come with me if you
want to live one box office if a
director makes a movie and no one shows
up to see it does it make a sound well
these two fellas don't have to worry
about that as they're responsible for at
least 300 of my hard-earned dollars
being spent at the theater and that
would have been more but I had to sneak
into Terminator 2 I was too young boy
felt good to get that off my chest hey
speaking of chest remember when that
alien busted through that dudes chest
and the accurately titled alien Ridley
Scott's first blockbuster in 1979 would
go on to gross almost 400 million
dollars worldwide adjusted for inflation
and that's not even in his top three
box-office achievements gladiator
made a shade under eight hundred million
dollars the Martian did six hundred
eighty million dollars and Hannibal the
movie about the guy who's the chef that
grossed 582 million dollars across the
globe all told Ridley Scott's catalog
has racked up over six billion dollars
on Planet Earth
and it sounds like I'm stacking the deck
for Ridley I am and it still doesn't
matter James Cameron is a box-office
juggernaut the likes of which we've
never seen when the guy emerges from the
icy depths of the bottom of the ocean to
actually make a film we all show up in
droves
remember how Ridley's 25 movies combined
to make six billion dollars yep yet
James Cameron surpassed that total with
two movies adjusted for inflation
Titanic made 3.8 billion dollars and
avatar added 3.3 billion dollars 7.1
billion now I feel bad calling Jim
unbelievable and it's not like Jim money
is a two-hit wonder you take all of his
movies especially his relationship with
a guy named Schwarzenegger who could be
a robot or a spy and you wind up with a
grand total of 9.5 billion dollars over
just eight movies and we'll give you an
extra hundred million dollars and you
want to count the Aquaman movie he did
on Entourage
James Cameron's directing Aquaman [ __ ]
you where'd you hear that Friendster
whether it's total box office or per
film average Cameron has an easy victory
here even though Ridley Scott's flicks
make on average 250 million dollars
worldwide
Cameron is a bankable 1 billion dollar
guy every time he hits the clamps Ridley
Scott those scores some points for
launching his career first and thus
giving James Cameron a property Lake
alien on which to further his own career
but in the words of Hudson in this round
it's game over man game over James
Cameron goes up
that's it man game over man game over
round two tomato meter audience score
here's where Ridley Scott has a chance
to even the match in a career spanning
six decades so far he's made critically
acclaimed films in a variety of genres
meanwhile that James Cameron guy just
keeps making crowd-pleasing blockbusters
right actually it's Cameron whose movies
have the higher average on the tomato
meter he's at 78% while Scott is on the
lower side but still fresh at 62% but
really has way more at-bats than James
so let's look at the best of the best
starring Eric Roberts the only thing I
know I am including James Cameron still
has the edge 1984's Terminator has a
perfect 100% besting 1979's alien which
is 98% Cameron also has aliens thanks
Ridley and terator to at 93% while Scott
has the dualist the Martian and Blade
Runner all in the low 90s unfortunately
for Ridley the only place where he
dominates Cameron is at the other end of
the spectrum you don't think this a bit
cold if you combine these directors most
rotten efforts Ridley Scott has made
nine of them including stinkers like a
good year and Exodus gods and kings
Cameron's only entering the rotten side
of things is piranha 2 spawning but hey
we all did things we regret in college
how about the audience score
it's a closer ballgame but Cameron still
gets the knob averaging 75 percent to
Scotts 67 percent can I say something
that right it's my show look there's
quality over quantity
but Ripley's quantity still has a ton of
quality in it what you're right maybe I
should talk less I respect a guy who's
obsessed with making movies consistently
and giving us something new every time
out but just because Cameron has made
fewer flicks that doesn't mean he isn't
giving us new takes and expanding the
horizons of what's possible in cinema
Ridley Scott has made some of my
favorite films ever gladiator
American Gangster Black Rain with
Michael Douglas it is awesome if I
remember correctly but as loud as I can
shout from the rooftops that I loved
watching Matt Damon grow potatoes on a
red
planted the tomato meter has spoken and
the audience has agreed James Cameron
wins the round and all the sudden is up
to nothing
[Music]
you're fired
round three iconic moment so now Ridley
Scott's back is against the wall and his
fans are hoping he can rally luckily
this round is all about the moments that
we the movie-going audience remember and
nothing says instant offense off the
bench like an alien popping through a
chest dear God
I'm home it's so good it was recreated
in 1987 Spaceballs any time Mel Brooks
makes fun of you
you did something right both directors
have had more than their fair share of
iconic moments as a matter of fact can
you imagine any Oscars montage ever
without a sweeping shot of the Titanic
or if Maximus bellowing are you not
entertained movies are just a bunch of
moments strung together and both Cameron
and Scott are masters of having the
story stick with us long after the film
has ended most of Jimmy C's best moments
are blockbusters storytelling at its
finest with a mix of real human emotion
combined with cutting-edge effects in
his earlier days this might result in
the suspense-filled claustrophobia of a
t800 threatening I'll be back or
everyone's favorite pretend Navy SEAL
Michael Biehn uttering the iconic come
with me if you want to live once the
higher-ups decided to give this
promising director you know a budget we
got massive reveals like the underwater
alien township in the abyss and the
stunning action sequences of Terminator
2
look at that liquid metal fella go
liquid metal it's the Crystal Pepsi of
the future kamerad would further both
his own storytelling and the visual
effects industry as a whole with his
beloved avatar we're still waiting on
the sequels but in the meantime feast
your eyes on an epic battle scene that
is for the very survival of Pandora
that's right it's not just a good
Valentine's Day gift card for your
significant other anymore
Pandora is also a planet full of
pterodactyls with plug and play
technology but if you really want a
conic then you have to go to the James
Cameron sensation that made heart swoon
break but ultimately go on of course I'm
talking about Tom Arnold and true eyes
she even took the ice cube trays out of
the freezer what kind of a sick [ __ ]
takes the ice cube trays out of the
freezer he was great
but sure I give Titanic points for
having a bevy of iconic shots personally
my most emotionally resonant moment is
the band continuing to play as the ship
is sinking as a comic I've done gigs
like that and just like the band my
check did not clear afterwards so bring
it on Ridley how can you counter all of
these stellar effects shots and some of
the biggest sci-fi blockbusters ever
well it appears mr. Scott strategy is to
spread the floor with virtually every
category of movie imaginable his
filmography could fill a blockbuster
video if that was still a thing with his
high concept outerspace sci-fi nightmare
alien it's the visceral imagery of human
versus xenomorph combat that begat all
those cool battles we'd see in James
Cameron's sequel aliens but Ridley can
also make us think about the future
we're weaving for ourselves
check out the underrated tears in the
rain sequence from Blade Runner
Oh moment
in time like tears rain he has the
emotional bandwidth and sweeping vision
required to put us right in the middle
of battle in diverse settings such as
the sprawling militaristic bloodbath in
Gladiator Black Hawk Down and Kingdom of
Heaven he can also give us the smaller
but no less impactful image of a simple
slap in the face
Frank Lucas may be a drug kingpin but
with one flick of her wrist
mama proves she can still grab him for
the weekend to meet to me more shaved
her head Matt Damon went to Mars Susan
and Gina drove off a cliff and Nic Cage
went even crazier than usual for this
guy hey buddy
ever heard of a lie have you ever been
dragged on the sidewalk and beaten to
you blood and Charlize Theron she agreed
to die one of the all-time preposterous
ly stupid deaths in cinematic history
why because a list SP ins respect a
master craftsman and Ridley Scott's
legacy of iconic moments earned him that
ranked so as bummed as I am that Tom and
Arnold making Bill Paxton pee his pants
and True Lies won't get James Cameron
the win in this round I am thrilled that
Ridley Scott gets the nod and is back in
the ball game it's two to one
keep pushing Ridley boss walls and now
it's time for the wild-card round
influence you'd be hard-pressed to find
any director of this generation or from
future generations you know after we get
that whole war against the Machine
things out of the way that don't cite
Ridley Scott or James Cameron as prime
influences on their careers just imagine
a horror movie fan who never got to see
alien or a sci-fi fan it was denied
terminator Blade Runner or avatar simply
put James Cameron has changed the
landscape of cinema forever he stood on
the shoulders of effects pioneers like
Spielberg Lucas and yes Ridley Scott to
make the theater experience feel more
intense realistic and memorable than it
ever was before plus he assisted in
writing Point Break which was directed
by his then wife Kathryn Bigelow did I
just say Point Break you're damn right I
did
that might even help him compete against
Top Gun he wants the ultimate gotta be
willing to pay the ultimate price
meanwhile it's fair to ask the question
do we even get James Cameron if not for
sir Ridley Scott yeah I said sir he's a
knight not only does that give him
points in this round it also gives me
relief that I never called him red dog
in this episode got the wrong guy pal so
he's got the knighthood thing he was
also listed as the 10th most influential
Brit in a 2004 vote which was before he
made classics like American Gangster the
Martian and prometheus
okay maybe promethease isn't a classic
but it's visually stunning and it's a
great reminder to all astronauts to stop
having sex in space just say no control
yourselves you filthy ethan's wait till
you get back home regardless of how you
feel about Prometheus II gotta admit
it's better than the counselor right
yeah American Cinematheque Award winner
sir Red Dog has been nominated for four
Best Director Oscars and though he's
still looking for his first win his
movies have won a total of nine Oscars
James Cameron owns a tuxedo as well as
his flicks have won 21 Oscars including
a Best Director statue for himself
thanks to that little boat movie these
fellows have an influence over
Entertainment the runs so deep we don't
even realize it sometimes Ridley Scott
directed that landmark 1984 Apple ad
that aired during Super Bowl 18 it had
something to do with George Orwell but I
love it because it distracted my family
from the fact that Marcus Allen and the
Raiders were embarrassing my beloved
Washington defense it was a disgusting
game and should never be re-aired James
Cameron got his start working on Roger
Corman models and even worked on the
special effects from Escape from New
York for good measure he was also the
first person to successfully perform a
solo dive to the bottom of the Mariana
Trench
now I'm not notion agra fur but I met
Richard Dreyfuss once and so I'll say
that that's pretty deep if it's legacy
and respect you want it's impossible to
go wrong with either director but even
though we don't get Cameron without
Ridley Scott in the year of our Lord
2020 I would have to lean towards James
Cameron to win this wildcard round of
influence I don't like going against the
British Knight but unfortunately
Judgment Day has arrived hasta la vista
baby
so James Cameron wins the rounds three
two one and I'd look like a completely
handsome jackass buy changed course now
and somehow gave my vote to Ridley Scott
right James Cameron is my winner but
let's just have some fun and ask
ourselves who wins in a fight between
Xenomorphs and terminators here's my
take so the terminators would have the
technology necessary to defeat the more
primitive aliens however we know once we
get aliens that predators are bound to
show up and not all the watery aluminum
in the world can save the machines from
the advanced hunting society and quality
teamwork showcased by predators
so aliens lose the terminators
terminators and lose the Predators one
alien sneaks away to go procreate then
John Connor goes back in time to start
mayhem all over again not since I played
Super Nintendo has one person loved
hitting the reset button as much as John
Connor yeah James Cameron edges by
Ridley Scott in my book but I can barely
read now it's up to you the faithful
viewer to render the real verdict
comment below right now with the
director you prefer and feel free to
give your logic behind said choice I'm
not even gonna ask the question because
I know I entertained you and if you
still need something productive to do
draw me like one of your french girls it
was either that or I'll be back what did
you want
[Music]